the unemployment rate is near a 50e low
and the US added 225,000 jobs a month
last year just about everywhere you look
people are talking about the strong jobs
Market resilient durable robust use the
word you want to use the job market is
absolutely solid it's one of the big
reasons money managers say they're
confident about gains for the stock
market in 2024 but when you dig into the
data there are four serious problems
that suggest the US jobs Market isn't as
strong as it seems the labor force data
revisions hours and wages and
unemployment claims I'll
explain most Americans and even some
Market Watchers only pay attention to
the big numbers when economic data are
released one of the main ones is the
government's monthly jobs report which
has shown the unemployment rate below 4%
since February 2022 but the historically
low rate is actually masking some
weakness particularly in the number of
people who are in the labor force in
December the jobs report showed that
845,000 people had dropped out that was
the 10th largest increase in the number
of people dropping out of the labor
force since the labor department started
tracking the data in 1975 Americans
dropped out of the labor force in 8 out
of 12 months last year leaving the US
with a net 694,000 fewer workers the
number of people dropping out of the
labor force is also a reason why the
unemployment rate is so low that sounds
strange but the unemployment rate
doesn't include people who who have
dropped out of the labor force it's
calculated by taking the number of
people who are unemployed and dividing
that by the total number of people who
are in the labor
force anyone who doesn't say they're
actively looking for a job is counted as
out of the labor force and lately the
folks dropping out of the labor force
have included more Prime AG workers or
those between 25 and 54 years old the
prime AG labor force participation rate
has fallen pretty consistently since
September the government also
overestimated the number of jobs the US
added in almost every month of 2023 the
Bureau of Labor Statistics releases the
nonfarm payrolls report each month which
estimates how many jobs were added by
American companies but the report also
tells us how many jobs its previous two
reports were off by in a typical year
some months are revised higher meaning
the BLS underestimated how many jobs
were ated and some months are revised
lower meaning they overestimated last
year every month except October was
revised lower it was the first time that
many months had been revised lower in
the history of the survey which dates
back to
1979 lizanne Saunders the chief
investment strategist at Charles Schwab
told me recently that the US saw a
similar pattern in 2007 and 2008 ahead
of the global financial crisis at the
time the labor market looked pretty good
lizanne said what we know now with all
the revisions is the backdrop was a lot
uglier and we've been seeing another
reliable recession indicator from the
jobs report a decline in real wages and
average hours worked while average
weekly earnings for Americans soared in
20121 and 2022 during the so-called
great resignation things reversed course
the tail end of 2023 average weekly
earnings for us workers fell in December
for the second time in 3 months when
adjusted for inflation that was largely
the result of a decline in the number of
hours the average American was working
reducing hours has long been an early
recession indicator it shows businesses
are looking to lower their labor costs
because they aren't making as much money
but they aren't yet ready to start
handing out layoffs the rise in the
number of continuing jobless claims has
also caught economists die the number of
people who continued to file claims for
unemployment Rose to the highest level
since 2021 in mid November and has
remained pretty high since then the
numbers have stayed under 2 million
which is low by historical standards but
the consistent increase in continued
unemployment claims even as initial
claims for unemployment Insurance have
been very low is unusual it shows that
people are having trouble finding work
once they're laid off and that's a sign
that the labor market may not be so
great for job Seekers which could
explain why so many are dropping out of
the labor force so what is all this tell
us about the US economy obviously the
labor market isn't falling apart lizanne
Saunders told me but all of this
weakness does show that there are cracks
forming that you wouldn't pick up if you
were analyzing the economy at the
headline level so as with everything
when you're thinking about how the
economy and the labor market are doing
make sure you read the fine
print